Let us now turn to the third problem solving method under this topic called
problem reduction. The method of problem reduction actually is quite intuitive.
I'm sure you use it all the time. Given the hard complex problem, reduce it.
Decompose it into multiple easier, smaller, simpler problems. Consider, for
example, computer programming or software design that I'm sure many of you do
all the time. Given a hard part of the address, you decompose it
with a series of smaller problems. How do I read the input? How do I process it?
How do I write the output? That itself is a decomposition. In fact,
one of the fundamental roles that knowledge plays is it tells you how to
decompose a hard problem into simpler problems.
Then once you have solutions to this simpler smaller problems.
You can think about how to compose the sub-solutions to the sub-problems into
a solution of the problem as a whole. That's how problem reduction works.